alors il ya une photo à regarder ces
longs juillet 84 il porte la cape et le
couvre chef de la confrérie du clos
montmartre à l'hôtel de ville de paris
ça aussi c'est une photo assez culte un
de jacques chirac alors ils n'ont pas
merci à eux
on a eu notre photo c'est en 86 que vous
l'avez celle où il a reçu une coiffe
traditionnelle à son arrivée à nouméa en
calydon nouvelle calédonie ça aussi
regarder ça c'est si incroyable et puis
y en a qui en est une autre
la même année il a été photographié avec
un collier de fleurs alors là il a été
encore plus loin
regardez donc c'est vrai que c'est voilà
toujours la même année jacques chirac
était photographe est en train
d'embrasser une habitante de guadeloupe
regardez c'est aussi c'est ça c'est vrai
alors c'est vrai que voilà mais c'est
fou parce qu'on verrait pas un autre
président faire ça il avait un physique
aussi
mine de rien ils font parler c'est vrai
qu'il était un très beau garçon et de la
tirah qu il avait énormément de succès
avec les femmes
bruno c'est vrai que c'était un
séducteur jacques chirac c'était un
c'était un séducteur oui là il a même
pris là il a même failli divorcer pour
essayer une journaliste
ah oui bon ça a été racontée bon c'est
vrai que nous faisons pour nous quand il
était premier ministre et ses pierres
juillet marie france garaud c'est le
conseiller de l'époque ils ont dit non
pas question
un premier ministre ne divorce pas
quelqu'un qui veut être président de la
république de divorce en termes 74-75 ça
posait des problèmes avec berne est vous
qui était très proche du couple valérie
jacques chirac c'était parce qu'on a vu
un extrait on peut même leur montrer
voilà l'ex trichez pas si vous l'avez
encore on va leur montrer une troisième
fois ce soir les jeunes ouvert mallette
chirac le voit voilà en train de draguer
une fille son retour on va le revoir une
troisième fois et c'est vrai que valérie
j'aimerais que vous réagissiez à cet
effet monsieur vous êtes vous étiez vous
êtes ami du couple
est ce que vous l'avez l'extrait
regardez c'est un extrait qu'on a montré
tout à l'heure
à ses côtés
[Musique]
il
mesdames et messieurs les élus mes chers
collègues je l'avais pas su si j'avais
plus frais venu pour cet événement unis
m
e
bon
je fais des idées trop de pékin
[Applaudissements]